can 穴ぼこ
ああああああ
はじめましてくぼゆかと申しますよろしくお願い致します
私はコンピューターとがインターネットの技術の分野の研究者なんですけれども
その中で日本の文化を生かすということを探求しています
例えば今までやってきたことは
浮世絵の構図というのはちょっとゆがんだ構図になっているんですけれどもそれを
コンピューターでつくるためのプログラムを作ったりとか
それから日本の美人画のデフォルメの顔をコンピューターで描くための計算式をつくっ
たりそういうような研究で博士論文を書いていきました
そういう中でちょっと気づいたことなんですけれども日本の美人画というのはこう
ちょっと歴史的にずらっと並べてみると
同じ時期に描かれた顔っていうのはそっくり
って言う
これは江戸時代の
浮世絵で完成さん美人といってその当時
街で声度で美人だというふうに言われていた3人の町娘が描かれているんですけれども
まあそっくり中大手本当に美人だサーんだろうかもよくわからないという状況なわけ
です
これは現代にも引き継がれていってちょっと似てませんか
今の若い女の子たち
も結構まあ重工のとレンダーの濃いお化粧日本の女の子はするのでちょっとは私なんか
から見るともう見分けがつかないような感じになってしまっているわけです
エコー化粧だけではなくっていなはこうスマートフォンもカメラで自撮りしたりした
ような顔とか
それからプリクラで作った顔というのもこうあのカメラを色々と駆使したり特価それ
から二画像処理を使ったりでみんな校そろって目を大きく顔小さくとするのでそういう
ふうにでこれをデフォルメをされているからどうも同じような顔にコミへ
てくるわけですそういう顔女の子たちは人に見せているっていうところに私はちょっと
興味を持ちまして
博士論文を書いた後はデフォルメの中でも日本の女の子たちが人に見せるときにする
デフォルメっていうのに焦点を絞って探求を派
で今日ちょっと話ししたいのは
これがそれを信じるやテクノロジーという風に呼んでいます今日お話ししたいことが
その日本の女の子たちが行っているで古命が実はこれからのインターネット社会におけ
るコミュニケーションに生かされるのではないかということなんです
またなんでかと思われるかもしれませんが実は日本の女の子たちが
一緒に始めたデフォルメが広く使われるコミュニケーションになるということが浮力
から結構あるんです
例えば平安時代のひらがなというのも中国から漢字が入ってきて男の人たちが漢字を
使ったのに対してそれをデフォルメしたひらがなをオーナー5人たちが
は買うな人たちが使いましたそれを今の私たちも使っているというわけです
それから絵文字というのも日本の恩
あの子たちが最初使い始めてそれが世界にも広がりました
それから先ほどちょっと話ししたこのつ携帯で文字どおりというのも最初に本能なのか
2001年頃に初めて
それがセルフィーなどと言って今世界に広がっているわけです
そういうふうに結構日本の女の子たちが最初に来始めたデフォルメというのはあの結構
絵文字にしても自撮りにしても最初は大人とか男性からバカにされたりするんです
けれどもひらがなもそうだったという話がありますが結構分かりやすくて簡単で実は
広がりやすいという特徴があります
なので私もこれからのコミュニケーション技術を探りたいために
日本の女の子たちのデフォルメの行動をサブっています
そういう中でちょっと面白い話がえーっ
あるので私は思っているので今日ちょっとお話しさせていただきたいと思います
プリクラーの話なんですがさっきもちょっと出てきましたがご存じですかプリックらー
は知ってはいらっしゃいますかでもまだあるのっていう感じで顔されている方も結構
多いと思うんですけれども実はプリクラで最もシェアの大きい会社のオンラインの
サービスの会員数が1000万人を超えているんですよ
2的には日本の女子中高大生の総数よりも上回るぐらいの数字なんですねそのぐらいの
人が関わっていたので私のこの女の子たちの観察も最もシェアの大きいフリュー
株式会社さの協力をいただきながらやっております
自然その面白い話というのが広いにフェイスコンテストという風に言って2012年に
あったんですが
プリクラままデフォルメした顔で応募するオーディションっていうのがありました
すでに26万人もの応募がありました
このコンテストのちょっとプロセスずを選考のプロセスをお伝えするんです
まずその人が撮ったプルプリクラ機の中で投票が行われて各ゲームセンターの一番と
いうのが選ばれます
その全国のゲームセンターも1番の人がインターネット十分に公開されてそこで一般
投票が行われます
そこで最終的に20人が上位20人が選ばれるんですが
このあとちょっと残酷なことがありましてその20人がリアルな舞台に集めさせられる
んですね
分かりますつまり26万人から20人になるところまではプリクラのデフォルメの顔で
インターネット投票で選ばれてきたのに最後にリアルなニンジンが強進められるわけ
ですね
ちょっとどんなことになるのかなと気になって私も見に行かせてもらったんですけれど
も
最終審査は芸能事務所のスカウトさんが来てその前で歌や踊り
を披露したんですが部屋冷やしての私だけで女の子たちはとても生き生きしていたのが
印象的でした
ちょっとこの出来事を整理させていただきます
まず彼女たちはリアルな実際の自分とそれからプリクラ上の自分という2種類の自分を
持っているわけです
これをリアルアイデンティティーとバーチャルアイデンティティーとここでは予防と
思うんですが
プリクラをしない方でも今実際の自分とそれから twitter とか
facebook の上の自分っていう2種類持っている
ハートインしは持ってらっしゃるんじゃないかと思いますがでここで女の子たちはこの
フリクラのデフォルメをバーチャルアイデンティティを作るために使ったということ
です
そしてもう一つ重要なのはヴァーチャルアイデンティティーでご理想的な顔を作った
そのままなりすますという手もあったと思うんです最終審査に来ないとか
でもそうじゃなくって彼女たちは実際に現れました
今このバーチャルアイデンティティというのは何の制約もなくて自由自在に設定する
ことができるのでそこで別人になりすまして悪いことをしてしまうとかっていうような
サイバー犯罪みたいなことというのが今とっても増えてきていてそれが夜中でもすごく
問題視されていますがそういう人たちというのはたぶん
おじ最後まで実際の自分は見せないようにすると思うんですね
もこの彼女たちは違って最後現れてそれで芸能事務所のスカウトさんの前で歌や踊りを
披露したわけです
つまりバーチャルアイデンティティでインターネット投票でご成功したことを
リアルな夢実現に生かそうとしたわけです
はこれからのインターネット社会を考えた時のバーチャルアイデンティティの活かし方
としてとても理想的なのではないかなというふうに私
これでよしちょっとここまでデフォルメデフォルメっていう話をしてきましたが
女の子たちがバーチャルアイデンティティの上で実際よりも良い姿を作ろうとすること
を
守るという風に言うんですねご存じですかもらって
ねえぞ6で実際に理想的に守ることができるともれていると喜ぶんですね
このちょっと彼女たち特有のこの言葉をもうちょっと掘り下げてみたいと私思いまして
先ほど最終審査に残った女の子のうちの1人をちょっとお茶にお誘いして
でよりお話を詳しく聞いてみることにしました
それで一番聞きたかったことをちょっと聞いてみたんですがなぜ守るのかということを
聞いてみました
すると結構困ってしまってあるいはそうだ何でだろうと言って困ってしまったんですが
でまぁ普通やはり皆さん多分やっぱりた汗に良く思われたいから守るんでしょうとね
思われますよねきっとね
私もそう思って聞いてみたんですが
前線そうじゃないこともないけどそうということもないというふうに答えました
なあごめんなさいねなんだけどじゃあやっぱり同性の女性の上に中国は胃瘻でそれを気
にして守るのかなというふうに思って聞いてみるとそれも全然違うこともないけどそう
でもないんだよね答え
最終的に色々と子を聞いていった結果出てきた答えが
自分らしくあるためというですよ
ってちょっと気になって他の女の子にもいろいろあノアを愛して同じ質問を聞いてみた
んですけれどもやっぱり行き着く所はここなんです
私はちょっとやっぱり驚きました最初から美人かの研究の時からこう
を消し落ちてもプリクラにしてもなんで若い女の子たちは金素敵な顔になるんだろう
っていうことも気になってこの探求を始めたの
それなのに家族彼女たちはそこに個性を感じているということ
これはどういうことだろうとこの謎解きたいなと思って今度はその後ちょっと1日
申し上げについてかせてくれと言って渋谷移動派の会合の1日ついてかせてもらいまし
た
ちょっとわかってきたことがありましてまああの彼女の木の芽を見ていただきたいん
ですが簡単にできた目ではないんですよ
まず私とプリクラにやっぱりついてがせてもらったんですが
ハンズプリクラはトレーニングですっていう風に言ってい
プリクラってミカサも頑張って誰でも彼はキレイになれるように機械化したものなので
そうな通してトレーニングなのかなと思って聞いてみるとまぁいっぱい機種があって
その日仕事にちょっとずつ曲は違うみたいなんですよね
同じ物を何度も繰り返し使うことによってその機種の曲を盗んでその pro
いくらもこのシャッタータイムにウィングに合わせてそのプリクラの画像処理に合わせ
た目の見開きをするんだというふうに言っています
すごいでしょすごいなあと林でそれからその後あのドラッグしたにもついて行かせて
もらったんですけれども
今つけてるつけますけどれだのなんていう風に聞いたら子4つぐらい出てきたのであり
これどういうことかなと思って
たらメーカーもバラバラの4つぐらいにつけまつ毛をこう切り刻んで組み合わせて自分
仕様にカスタマイズして使う
ているわけなんですね
そんな話を聞いているうちにはだんだんと私も彼女たちの顔からこう個性が見えてき
ました
どうも話を聞いていると感じも目を大きくすることに一生懸命ですけれども
目を大きく生ばするほどいいというわけでは全然ないみたいなんですよね
加工すればするほどいいのではなくって加工しすぎると世話もれ過ぎであってもれて
ないことと同じだという風に言うんです
じゃあこの漏れてるともれ過ぎの境界は何なんだろうということで私はこれちょっと
プリクラメーカーさんの協力もいただきながら調べていった
加工をどんどんどんどんと増やしていくと9匹に個別人間が高まるところがあるんです
ね
私もれ過ぎの坂と呼んでるんですけれども
彼女たちが目指しているのはその直前のところそこが漏れてるなんだということが
わかっ
まぁ要するに鉱物心感が全然ないのは直つまらないけれども別人感がありすぎるのも
また良くなくてその最後のギリギリのところに小さな自分らしさを残すということを
追求しているということが赤い
それから先ほど私から見ると同じ顔に見えるという風にお話ししましたがこれも
と分かってきて
どうも私のようなコミュニティの外にいる人から見るとそっくりに見えるんですが
彼女たちどうしてはすごい妻が見えてるらしいんですよね
彼女たちを自分らしさを大事にすると言っていますがいきなりドーンと自分らしさを
出すのはちょっと格好悪いという風に考え
まずはそのコミュニティで共有している基準を守った上でその上で小さな自分らしさを
作るということに
を追求しているということがわかってきました
お話聞いていて私ちょっと気づいたんですけれども
伝統的な武道とか芸事で考えられている
4針という考えに彼女たちの b 好きは近いなというふうに思ったんです
ご存じですかねこれあのまあなんとかどうと言われているもので考えられているもの
ですが
水分がすごいからといっていきなり新しい流派を作りますとかっていうのはとても良く
ないことと昔からされていって
まずはその流派をにと家族して底の方をしっかり守ってそれが難しいわけですけれども
そこでしっかりと形を守ることができて師匠に認められて初めて破って離れて新しい
流派を作ることができた人はすごいという考え
どうも彼女たちの交尾好き遅くこれに近いなというふうに思ってきました
なのでまぶしに武士道があるようにギャルにもギャルドがあるんだということがわかっ
てきたわけです
でこの考え方が私はどうもこれからのインターネット社会にとても役立つのではないか
なと思っています
高天インターネットの社会の世界での問題というのは
リアルな世界では個人というのはほとんどの人が好会動画費用とか学校に属している
状態で守られているわけですけれども
バーチャル世界っていうのは個人がこうにさらされて危険です
中で彼女たちのやり方というのはコミュニティの外の人から見ると見分けがつかない
ようにしてしまって個人を守ることができて
でもコミュニティの中の人たちから見ると個性がこう見えるようにして言って
コミュニティの中の人たちとはリアルなコミュニケーションをやっていくというやり方
ができている
これはこうバーチャル世界とリアル世界の良いところ
生かしながら安全に発展していくというようなやり方とても良いやり方じゃないかなと
思う
これは google の元社長今会長のエリックシュミットさんが2025年の
ネット社会を展望して本に書いていることとも重なると思うんです
彼はこの風に言っていて今誰でもこれから dr 世界とバーチャルして帰って二つの
世界を生きていくことになりますか
この多次元的な世界を最もうまく当たっていけるものが未来の世界が優位に立つだろう
ということを言っています
まさに彼女たちがやっているそのやり方はこの音に生かされるのではないかなという
ふうに思う
なので私もちょっと彼女たちの行動をヒントにして新しいコミュニケーション技術の
説教しようということを今ちょっとたプランでいるところなんです
ちょっと今日私がお話ししたような女の子たちというのはアマゾンでしかしたり
ちょっと後部割と反逆的な感じもあって皆様から見るとつきにくいタイプの女の子かも
しれませんがでもそういう子たちこそ実は未来のヒントを持っているのではないかと
思うんです
なのでちょっとそういうような普段はことつきにくい人ほど自分のも
てない能力を持ってたりするものなのでぜひそういう共同作業にも好ショット一歩
踏み出すきっかけにしていただけたらいいなと思います
もありがとうございました